what's left non faremo un altro io
l'altro dico solo wow
perché allora ragazzi io questo video lo
volevo fare praticamente subito una
volta successa sta cosa
sono passati già due o tre settimane
come potete vedere c'è test mai bass
papaina le parole in italiano anche
allora praticamente cosa è successo è
successo che davide o meglio davy o
meglio dei difensori mi ha regalato un
basso facciamo questa premessa non
suonerò il basso in questo video perché
so suonare poche rob e sto imparando è
normale perché mi hanno dato uno
strumento nuovo e quando prendi uno
strumento nei ghetti è difficile non
avevo mai provato un basso una levità
giù mai
questa della prima volta io seguo david
a da mesi
so che suonare il buzz immaginavo con sé
difficile infatti è così la cosa che ho
notato più più assurda io che vengo
dalla chitarra don col de police la
diversità che ho notato subito proprio
me feeling è stato proprio il fatto di
dover fare un chilometro e mezzo quando
cambi corda perché le dita la chitarra a
sei corde sono tutte molto più vicine
quindi per cambiare accordi metti le
dita cell esposti molto meno che nel
basso questa è stata la cosa più mamma
mia da quando ha iniziato a suonarlo
comunque sto ai micro ring tra un po mi
metto su fever così poi il rischio che
devi mi ha soldi in uno dei feriti
comunque ragazzi allora perché sto
facendo questo video perché volevo
raccontarvi il secondo come è andata la
faccenda perché fas tra ridere non sto
scherzando vi spiego come è andata
innanzitutto non mi fate commenti se
sembro tipo hanzo di overwatch ma i
capelli ragazzi lo sapete come quindi lo
di ios che ero sul divano
stavo giocando allo switch cosa è
successo semplicemente mia madre era in
balcone e dal balcone vede arrivare il
corriere entra in casa e tutto eccitato
mi dice guarda che forse vi sono
arrivati i tasti della tastiera
io gli ho regalato una tastiera un
accordo sono saltati due tastini nel
corso del tempo quindi li ha ordinati
per lui arriva per lui questi due tasti
sono come se vuoi ricevere una
playstation 5 adesso in questo momento
la regalo lui era tutto fomentato da
serie b sono arrivati i tasti della
tastiera che ha ordinato da londra un
casino per avere i tasti della tastiera
era tutto frammentato per questa cosa
la barbie siamo in duemila in sto
condominio figura di 6 corriere per te
cena come cacchio tempo 20 secondi e
citofono non noi detrick non ci posso
credere ovviamente di son arrivati dalla
sfida tastiere tra tutti quelli che va
va avranno ordinato cosi sto periodo
corre tutto eccitato giu torna su e
torna con un pacco che era grosso e ve
lo faccio vedere io contro grosso così
niente torna su un po affranto perché ha
detto mica questa è è per mio figlio gli
ordinato due tasti da tastiera e questo
gli è arrivato godzilla che vabbè
comunque arrivato sulla co gigante io ho
detto io lo guardo mi guarda io guardo
voi e kaki nel blog e all'inizio pensavo
che avesse inviato della roba lavorativa
perché ovunque spa sto lavorando sto
facendo delle robe difesa fosse lavoro
lo guarda di guarda non stavo aspettando
niente
scartiamo lo lo scarto mentre lo scarto
le leggo nella nell'imballaggio
strumenti musicali è una roba del genere
non microsot già scritto ma tipo
strumenti musicali qualcosa e quindi
mette lo sto scherzando dico ma cacchio
marketing e perché poi la dimensione era
quella di una chitarra
non mi ammazza la oppure di un basso
dove lo scarto tirò fuori e do vedo vedo
un basso lavorato per un minuto buono
così ho fatto proprio due più due e ho
detto a nome non potrà mai essere per
mille motivi uno perché vabbè dai dai
non può mai essere stato rumori dai non
è possibile due non sa neanche il mio
indirizzo vabbè che quello lo può
recuperare ma proprio una una lap da
l'ipotesi più assurda del mondo c'è da
an possibile quindi non sarà ovviamente
non sono stato lui quindi ho contattato
mio amico che mi aveva detto che mi
avrebbe spedito qualcosa per il mio
compleanno ma questo mio amico io con lo
conosco mi avrebbe spedito una roba
molto più slim tipo un libro tipo una
lattina non basso patio l'ho contattato
io ho detto carlo lo so che non sei
stato tu però toglimi la curiosità mamma
mi ha inviato un basso astro mio amico
l'ho chiamato ho detto che mi fa no no
no no macché basso ma sarà stato
sovrastato devi fi comfort storia mi
come ha detto così detto guarda te lo
giuro ci ho pensato anch'io però mi
ovviamente non può mai essere una
cosa del genere quindi per quello che
chiama lo so che non sei stato tu però
sto cercando di capire o non sono stato
io non sono stato io chiedo a mio padre
mi pare che in un idea ci ordinato due
tasti della tastiera è arrivato un basso
ragazze blu si vede troppo ma che non
non lo so non so perché mi è arrivato un
basso e l'ho detto ma vuoi vedere che
veramente però non è possibile che sia
stato dei vivai voto come fa magari ha
chiesto qualcuno che conosco ho chiamato
due persone la prima chiama mio manager
mike ha scritto nella mail di lavoro non
lo so chiama mio manager pronto pino ave
lorenzo sapete così chiama mi hai fatto
inviare o mi ha inviato tu o qualcuno ha
inviato un basso a casa mia
no chao chiamo giampiero chiamo
giampiero e dico non sarà stato mai
giampiero ma c'è una probabilità che
sappia perché è un passo secondo me
qualcuno da qualche parte sarà arrivato
stamane che si è materializzato nel
corriere dai pronto pronto però tu
adesso io gli ho detto di misano è vero
che nei referti faccio questo che sta
montando il video tu adesso mi dici una
cosa lei mi dici tutta la verità di
quello che sai per cortesia a me a casa
mia è arrivato un basso tu per caso ne
sai qualcosa e vi fa pro siediti e io ok
però allora io sono in contatto con lei
e lui per il tuo compleanno mi ha
chiesto di dargli il tuo indirizzo
perché voleva inviarti un regalo quello
è il tuo regalo
ok
ero in crisi sono ancora io lo sono
ancora è quello il fatto io lo sono
ancora incredibilmente emozionato per
mille motivi
allora lasciamo stare gli si tratta di
davy facciamo finta che sia una persona
qualunque
già il solo il fatto che tu non mi hai
mai incontrato di persona e ci tieni a
farmi un regalo è una cosa bellissima
punto anche mi avesse scritto slap like
now in un bigliettino e me l'avesse
fatto recapitare a casa sarei stato
contentissimo lo stesso perché è proprio
il gesto capito di essersi interessato
di dove abito per potermi inviare
qualcosa quindi solo l'interessamento
per me vuol dire tantissimo per una
persona che non ho mai incontrato per la
quale tra l'altro provo una profonda
stima perché questo lo sapete 1 youtuber
che seguo come seguivo ai tempi più di
pipe
e così attualmente io pd poi non lo
segue più da un po perché da quando ha
lasciati gameplay
io sono innamorato di gameplay vabbè non
c'è bisogno di spiegarlo
quindi per me adesso più di paia me
piace molto però non lo seguo più come
una volta seguo devi come seguivo più di
pai una volta perché sono innamorato
anche della musica davy oltre che farmi
ridere è stato proprio in grado di farmi
innamorare del concetto che c'è dietro
uno strumento come il basso e quindi ma
questo da mesi e quindi venendo anche
nella famiglia dove si suona eccetera ho
iniziato a seguire devi in modo più
serio quindi ricevere un ma anche fosse
stato ripeto un bigliettino con su
scritto tanti auguri slackline ausl
effetti la faccia non lo so sarei stato
al settimo cielo perché una persona che
stimo enormemente si è informata per
sapere il mio indirizzo
poi si tratta di un passo c'è ma dai di
che cosa parliamo quindi ancora
incredibile giorno il massimo e il
massimo il massimo il massimo della
storia che potesse accadere è accaduto
talmente incredibile che non ci potevo
credere ha detto no vabbè dai c'è un
basso non sarà già e rai e per me avere
un bar però l'ho visto detto no non ci
posso credere
so cosa fare per tutta lavoro antenna e
quindi già ero contento così quando ho
saputo che è stato david et no dai non
ci posso veramente credere quindi non è
tanto l'oggetto è il pensiero quindi è
stata la cosa più inaspettata allo
stesso tempo gradita della mia vita non
sto esagerando provato un'emozione
incredibile e niente vorrei comunque io
ho dato non l'ho ringraziato subito
perché non trovo le parole per
ringraziarlo ci ho messo tipo qualche
ora ma di norma chiunque prenderebbe il
telefono grazie veramente lippi l'aveva
io no perché non sapevo non riusciva a
trovare proprio le parole per esprimere
una roba una contentezza mai provata
prima
comunque questa era quando devi farlo
formi e regala un basso grazie davide se
gli stai seguendo questo video non lo so
ho apprezzato da morire questo già lo
sai perché alla fine the road e alla
fine glie l'ho detto ai ragazzi non è
che non ho detto anche a lui guarda non
trovo le parole giuste per ringraziati
dico grazie ma non non è abbastanza
quindi spero che tu riesca a capire che
cosa c'è dietro questo grazie anche se
solo un grazie perché c'è tanto dentro
dietro questo grazie c'e veramente tanto
signori degli five four questo tipo di
persona
quindi forse un po di orgoglio possiamo
averlo
ad eseguirlo questo video finisce qua
iscritti al canale sia stata vari
scritti anche alcuni dei tra l'altro
spero di riuscire a rendere giustizia
iscriviti a che schiaccia il tasto mi
piace lasciate un commento se volete qua
sotto e noi come sempre ci rivediamo a
un prossimo video è la ragazzi
poi io non non so veramente cosa dire
sono in un momento mistico in cui non so
che cazzo dire non so come scrive non so
neanche come scrivergli e l'ho capito
cioè non so come dire guarda siamo
arrivati ad un punto in cui non mi
ritrovo a non saper come reagire ad una
cosa del genere però capito c'è una cosa
che proprio non me l'aspettavo ma
neanche come per salute
[Musica]